call the border secure I think that  there is no question that we have to do  with the president and I asked Congress  to do is the first request we make  pass  a bill the border is secure but we also  have a broken immigration system in  particular over the last four years  before we came in and it needs to be  fixed we're gonna have two million  people across this border for the first  time ever you're confident this border  is secure we have  a secure border in that that is a  priority for Any Nation including ours  in our Administration  she is so extraordinarily vapid and  between her and Biden it's like Biden  doesn't know what he's saying and we'll  just read anything with her it's as if  they put her out there having no  knowledge of anything and she strings  together words in the most circular way  to say absolutely nothing